ah c'est bon c'est bon sens tu lis les
palpitations le stress l'énervement à
j'ai eu le temps de rencontrer quelques
personnes avant et puis ça aide aussi à
me mettre dans le dans le bain on parle
justement lien ancrage mais les liens et
les ancrages ont tous déjà été faible
avec certaines personnes pillent c'est
un honneur pour moi d'être ici ce soir
et déjà d'être habité et déjà d'être
habité par une belle émotion qui qui
m'habite à chaque fois que j'ai
l'occasion de partager
s'il y est extraordinairement puissants
et qui survivent à la mort d'un proche
je vous propose d'en rire de lire cette
citation là qui dit ouvre la porte de la
paire derrière se tient où se cache la
guérison
on a tous des parts on va en avoir
d'autres
mais j'espère que mon petit partage ce
soir vous vous donnez la fois le courage
de regarder vos pairs en pleine face et
de vous en libérer
il peut être encore mieux de vous en
servir pour peut-être accompagné
d'autres personnes qui vont vivre départ
similaire la part à laquelle je fais
face à ce moment là de ma vie il ya
plusieurs années c'est la peur de voir
ma mère mourir et la peur de perdre ma
mère ça vous la présenter marie marie
poulin qui est décédé à 49 ans d'une
maladie qu'on appelle l'alcoolisme
pour ceux et celles qui me connaissent
vous connaissez peut-être mon père jean
lapointe jean lapointe qui a souffert
d'alcoolisme et qui a même donné son nom
à une fondation à une maison pour aider
d'autres alcools et comme lui c'est
plutôt ironique de voir une heure une
femme la sienne ma mère mourir lentement
d'une maladie qui aurait pu tuer mon
père et mon père comme un chat de
plusieurs vies s'en est toujours sorti
toujours rebondi après si rechute mais
pas ma main et d'assister à une lente
noyade une lente agonie une lente mort
d'une personne proche comme ta mère
c'est épouvantable
on vit énormément d'impuissance tous les
membres de ma famille et moi même nous
vivions de l'impuissance
et puis en même temps moi j'ai 26 ans ce
moment et je vois ma mère tranquillement
s'en allait vers la mort ayant une
partie moins qu'il le voit et qui ne
l'acceptent pas qui dans déni total et
qui ne veut pas le voir mais il ya une
autre partie de moi c'est le petit jean
marie qui ne veut pas perdre sa mère qui
ne veut pas qu'elle n'abandonne a rejeté
dans cette dualité là tout le long des
derniers mois et les dernières semaines
de la vie de ma mère et à son entrée
ultime dernière à l'hôpital
ça peut être très très longues quelques
jours où on a dû se rendre à l'évidence
que maman allait mourir
mais il ya quelque chose en moi qui ne
l'acceptent pas qu'il ne voulait pas le
voir et je pourrais même pas imaginer ma
vie sans ma mère c'était une grande part
arrivent les dernières heures du vivant
de ma main je suis à son chevet j ma
copine de l'époque et présenté ya ma
soeur maryse ma grande soeur qu'il est
on voit ma mère qui commence à arrêter
de respirer
elle fait de l'apnée si vous avez déjà
accompagner quelqu'un dans la mort vous
savez ce que c'est quand une personne
arrête de respirer pendant quelques
secondes et pour la respiration réparé
mais je vous dis qu'à chaque fois que ma
mère arrêtée de respirer moi je pensais
que moi
amour et alors je les ai lui serrer la
main et je me souviens même l'avoir dit
non papa je pas prêt et le fait ce
manège là plusieurs reprises d'arrêter
de reprendre sa respiration jusqu'à un
moment où il ya une infirmière qui
rentre dans la chambre et qui viennent
nous chuchoter à l'oreille devriez
peut-être appeler votre papa pivot ça
parce que ça sent la frite maintenant 20
en train de partir et moi je les accepte
pas pire que ça je panique à l'idée de
voir maman mouret à chaque fois qu à la
réalité moi je me suis servi de ce
moment là pour sortir de la jambe
ma soeur est hélas ma copine et là je me
dis oh - maman de mon repos tout seul si
elle a à mourir mais au moins est pas
tout seul moi je suis parti chercher mon
père émissaires alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils t'arriver cas moi je suis
parti maman est partie si je suis revenu
une heure plus tard avec mon père
émissaire et en rentrant dans la chambre
j'ai vu le corps inerte de ma mère et
j'y crois encore que c'est possible
qu'elle ne soit pas morte mais non elle
est décédée
et là je vous dis la mort d'un proche ça
fait mal ça fait mal physiquement ça
fait mal aux survivants est tellement
moi j'ai senti une main invisible
venez m'arracher une partie du coeur et
ça c'était brutal comme douleur gilles
dumas pleuré j'ai même crié les jours
ont passé les semaines les mois et je
revois encore dans ma tête l'image de ma
main sur son lit morte qu'il ya quelque
chose qui déconnecte un petit peu dans
ma tête je me dis ah mais c'est ma main
si son corps mais c'est pas ma main donc
qu'est-ce qui fait exister maman
quelques secondes avant que le site plus
maman mais tu sais ce que c'est l'âme
une fois qu'on marque ce qu'on voit
quelque part donc j'ai commencé à me
questionner sur la vie après la mort
justement récemment amené à me
questionner tellement que j'ai lu plein
de livres là dessus et j'ai senti aussi
un élan m'habiter de faire de
l'accompagnement de fin de vie chez les
enfants et les adolescents
plusieurs années plus tard et on dirait
que la mort de ma mère avait ouvert mes
yeux vous connaissez peut-être la
citation c'est la mort ferme les yeux du
mourant mais ouvre ce du vivant alors
moi j'ai les yeux qui se sont ouverts
grand sur la vie j'ai commencé avec
l'organisme le camp avec sainte justine
avec des formations décor ips prendre
une formation pour accompagner les
enfants les adolescents et j'en ai
accompagné quand même plusieurs puits
fait quand même un aparté parce que qui
accompagne qu'il m'excuse mais lisant
femme accompagne aujourd'hui donc j'ai
peut-être accompagné des enfants mais
les accords ils sont encore un mois sont
très présents - et il y en a parmi ces
enfants là et ces adolescents qui m'a
profondément marqué mais juste avant de
vous présenter ce garçon là jamais
j'avais eu l'occasion d'accompagner
quelqu'un jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à sa dernière respiration ça
m'était jamais arrivé puis lui avoue que
si le hasard qui fait que tu fais dans
la chambre d'un enfant ou d'une personne
puis lorsqu'elle ces personnes vont
mourir ça se soit pas l'ours explique la
maman soit parti fumer darby de rené il
enfin décédé pendant ce temps là alors
moi de tous les enfants que j'avais
accompagné jamais j'avais été prise lors
du moment de mourir et le ça m'amène à
vous parler de l'oracle le rap ils ont
19 ans que j'ai rencontré à l'époque que
je co animer le téléthon des étoiles ou
le téléthon de la recherche sur les
maladies infantiles
j'avais fait une entrevue avec laurent
avec sa famille avec ses amis on l'avait
fait un portrait tous les animateurs et
les animatrices à cette époque là on
était jumelée avec une personne
cette année on m'avait demandé 70e'
d'accompagner laurent et faire une
entrevue avec lui et ça tellement
cliquer avec la famille de laurent avec
laurent lui-même que même le rendement
demandé
j'aimerais ça soit avec moi jusqu'au
bout c'est tout un cadeau bien en même
temps ça me faisait peur parce que
jusqu'au bout ça veut dire de voir
quelqu'un mourir est la dernière
personne que j'avais vu mourir devant
moi c'était ma mère est tellement
j'avais paniqué que j'étais sorti de la
pièce je te pouvait pas rester alors
l'horreur je le vois pendant quelques
semaines suite au téléthon des étoiles
ont créé un beau lien et la veille de sa
dernière arrivée cette dernière rentrée
à l'hôpital les parents m'appellent pour
me dire on rentre laurent et on voir
besoin de toi demain parce que c'est son
dernier voyage à l'hôpital et laurens
l'eau juste pour vous tracer le portrait
le symbole homme là qui aux véhicules à
100 à la bhl il vivait de façon intense
c'est lui qui connaît les shots à
l'hôpital c'est lui qui disait moi je
veux de la chimio non je veux pas chimio
je veux de l'occident et moi je m'en
vais à hawaï et avec ma famille et moi
je vais être capable de faire des tripes
là bas donc vous vous ma compagne est là
dedans c'est lui qui était le chef
d'orchestre de sa vie et même les
cowboys fringants lyon écrit une chanson
c'est un de ses groupes préférés
et si la tête haute donc vous allez
faire une petite recherche sur google la
tête haute
les cowboys fringants et site de leur
rendons par et juste retenir la chanson
et une partie la chanson qui dit j'ai
tout surmonté la tête baissée
mais si je redescends la côte ça sera la
tête de ces lorrains tout lâcher alors
moi j'arrive chez moi à fin de journée
je reçois téléphone effectivement c'est
des parents de laura sylvain unicode
pour me dire on a besoin tu as on a
besoin de toi viens nous rejoindre à
l'hôpital ça presse c'est la fin alors
moi j'ai embarque dans l'auto j'habite
tout près d'hôpital sainte-justine mais
comme un zombie comme sur le pilote
automatique
je me file chez vers sainte justine puis
j'ai la panique j'ai l'anxiété qui
embarque il joue pas bien mais j'ai
promis à laurent laurent m'a demandé
d'être jusqu'au bout je sais ma promesse
alors je rentre à l'hôpital je me vois
marcher lentement un pas à la fois je me
dirige vers
l'ascenseur je monte au deuxième où la
leur dans sa chambre et j'arrive
les portes s'ouvrent qui je vois arriver
nicole la maman de laurent et qui
viennent bois qui me regarde dans les
yeux et après ses deux mains am les
mains sur les épaules comme samedi
jean-marie on a besoin de toi laurent
s'en va c'est toi le professionnel c'est
toi qui accompagnent des enfants là on a
besoin de toi moi je suis en train de
faire dans mes culottes
je veux partir je panique j'angoisse et
je ne sais pas qu'est ce que je fais ici
je me sens comme un imposteur
je me dis sont fous de me laisser avec
laurence a pas de bon sens mais écoute
je suis nicole elle se dirige vers la
chambre de son fils elle oublie pas
moins grand et je vois laurent étendue
sur son lit
je vois ça soit réuni geneviève qui lui
tient la main assis sur le coin du lit
je vois les grands-parents de lorrains
en retrait je vois si tu es si
l'infirmière de leur enclos qui qui qui
qui m'a terminent tous qui accompagne le
tout les par la famille et là des mois
je rends gibbard je vais pas entrer au
niveau de cette phrase leur ouvre la
porte de la paire d'arrières se tient la
guérison alors sa porte s'est ouverte et
chez reavie loges vola mais je vois tout
le monde et je sens la tension
évidemment d'une famille qui va perdre
leur fils puis oublié pour que en plus
laurent un jeune frère qu un autre
cancer quelques temps avant que mélo lui
il va bien il est en rémission
alors le lyonnais qui est en train de
mourir s'il a alors germé stade je
regarde la scène et je vois le rat
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'ils pensent
il fait de l'apnée comme maman il
commence à respirer experts et là ça
s'arrête
moi je panique tout le monde panique
surtout geneviève geneviève la soirée et
nuit de l'art elle est assise sur le
coin
apprend là mais de là il ya le sa
fanfare
j'y vois les épaules monte tellement
qu'à panique moi je panique
geneviève panique mais laissez passer de
quoi j'ai comme oublié ma panique
je n'ai même pas fait par exprès ça
s'est fait tout seul et je me suis focus
hiver
geneviève qui avait besoin de moi alors
je suis arrivé je me suis levé et j'ai
mis mes deux mains sur les épaules de
geneviève qui était au petit qui était
en panique et j'ai flatter le dos comme
on flatte le dos d'un enfant qui vient
de faire un cauchemar dit non violent
j'ai juste 7 sur tout doucement il senti
les épaules de joliette dessin j'ai
senti sa respiration reprend et moi
aussi j'ai repris ma respiration on a
regardé laurent et leur a repris notre
inspiration expiré
quelques secondes ils reprennent autre
respiration l'espère mon latin
regarde là on est pendus à son souffle
le souffleur drapeau c'était si
l'infirmière regarde leur apprend les
signes vitaux le regard si laurent
partie tout doucement comme ça avec le
départ de laurent est partie ma part je
n'ai plus jamais eu peur et j'ai
accompagné des enfants des adolescents
qui sont ma jusqu'au bout et je n'ai
jamais jamais pas je n'ai jamais paniqué
n'a pas répartie
quel beau cadeau à ce que leur réserve
et ça qui m'a demandé de l'accompagner
jusqu'au bout est ce qu'il y avait eu
une intuition
quand me demande de la compagnie qui
m'offrait ce cadeau là je saurai jamais
par contre je suis éternellement
reconnaissant
en valeur c'est ouvrir la porte de la
peur derrière se cache la guérison
dans certains cas la peur c'est toi qui
va ouvrir la porte de la peur c'est toi
qui vont rentrer dans la porte voilà
défoncer des fois c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui va l'ouvrir pour twente
puis une fois que la porte est ouverte
il ya des gens qui vont être poussées de
force comme un saut en parachute lundi
inspecteurs des fois il m'a dit arrête
de glander sorte mais il ya des gens qui
vont avoir la délicatesse la
bienveillance de sentir ta peur de te
prendre par la main et amenés à
traverser en te regardant ce post payé
avec moi à ses seuls qui a dû clairement
fait il m'a accompagné jusqu'au puits
pour moi d'être ici pour vous ce soir de
rendre hommage à lorin de le rendre
éternel
c'est un beau cadeau que moi je lui fais
un en parlant de lui et transposé moi
c'est mon souhait je vous souhaite de
transposer cette histoire est de vous
dire que prochaine fois que j'ai peur je
vais la regarder en pleine phase vapeur
puis je vous souhaite une magnifique
guérison c'est une belle soirée merci de
votre attention il merci de m'avoir
accueilli dans mes émotions dans ma
vulnérabilité qui est aussi maintenant
rendu une force
merci mal